Charles Hamilton author of the book Adam
Clayton Powell jr. political biography
of an American dilemma who was mr.
Powell
many people and that was the intriguing
aspect of him he was a civil rights
leader he was a congressman he was a
preacher he was a playboy he was
terribly controversial throughout his
career and when you say this about other
people he was people are many different
kinds and types it was really true with
him and I had both fun and frustration
trying to answer that one question who
was this man
why did you write it well number of
reasons I'm a political scientist and
I'm a political scientist who
specializes in race and politics in the
United States here was a fellow who for
about thirty years was one of the more
important and interesting figures and
the American political scene locally and
nationally and not much was known about
him and so I wanted to make sure that I
could capture that career with all of
its controversies and dynamism before
too long he's been dead now for almost
twenty years my students at around the
country and at Columbia have very faint
memories oven I thought that's
unacceptable so I began my first
interview he died in sit in 72 April my
first interview was in December of 72 I
put it down and then I picked it up
again about four or five years ago and
decided this is unacceptable I must do
this book it really to fill in the
record
check the get check the gaps and that's
the reason I did it and Plus given the
nature of this fellow but going back to
your first question it was a challenge
I admired him and I was frustrated with
him and those two emotions continued
throughout the entire research in
writing of the book where are you now
where am I in the sense of teaching I'm
on the faculty at Columbia University I
teach political science and the
department department of political
science there and I've been there now
for about I shouldn't be so imprecise I
should know exactly how long I've been
been there for 21 years 22 years right
there next in that next door but in
Harlem and got a chance to have gotten a
chance both professionally and
personally to learn that terrain which
spawned Adam Clayton Powell and so am i
writing the book would to me
professionally was a natural that's that
also contributed to my interest quite
frankly I got to know an awful lot of
the people who worked with him worked
against him and got to know to a certain
extent that community and the church the
Abyssinian Baptist Church which was
fundamentally important to his career he
was born where he was born and he was
born in New Haven Connecticut and bred
and Harlem he was born in one place bred
and another bred meaning it that that
started 6 months so after after he was
born his family moved to to New York his
father took over Abyssinian Baptist
Church in 1909 he was born in 1908 so
he's really a child of Harlem but
equally as important he's a child of
privilege and a child who was terribly
pampered at a time when few people black
or white in this country had much in the
way of resources
he had a nanny black family he always
grew up in a very comfortable
circumstance he never had a day
of poverty want in his life in Harlem
growing up in Harlem they dressed in a
little Lord Fauntleroy suits this was a
very intriguing background you know then
and now for that kind of fellow one of
the things that you say play a role and
in his life and here's a picture I mean
is that he was mistaken at different
times for being a white man oh
absolutely
if he were to walk in here now and you
and I didn't know it
he'd have to tell us he was white he was
black because he looked white absolutely
so family and for a long time I strike
not for a long time but for a while he
passed for white to use that the lexicon
of that that process he passed for white
when he was in college at Colgate
University he pledged a white fraternity
he lived in a white dormitory he was
found out by the fraternity when they
investigated his background as far as I
can tell from that point on he never
crossed that line attempted to cross
that racial lie his sister however about
8 to 10 years older than he did pass for
white in the 1920s when she worked on
Wall Street in a secretarial job that
was not an uncommon phenomena for people
of his complexion and then and not so
now but and his father was quite white
looking and its whole family and there's
also it's also clear that while they did
not deny their racial identity there
were time so they would go on summer
vacations go to the south they loved
fishing his father and he loved fishing
they would take the train south your
listeners may be too young to know that
at times after you came to a certain
point in the mason-dixon line they
separated the races
colored in this place white here they
never moved and no one ever questioned
them and they never call it their
attention so there was always this
subtle aspect of passing you see that it
was a kind of game that people play that
which I'm going to suggest and I suggest
in the book also I think is contributed
to his cynicism he was in Congress for
how long
he went to Congress in 1945 elected in
44 sauna and 45 stayed till 67 at which
point they excluded him came back in 69
a swim court ruled that his exclusion
was unconstitutional um so then he was
in there from forty five to sixty seven
and then from 69 to 70 Charlie Rangel
the congressman defeated him in 1970 in
a tight race primary race in Harlem now
Powell is no longer chair of a major
committee no longer having his scene had
seniority he was stripped of his
seniority he was denied full pay because
they had the Congress had exacted
$25,000 from his pay to pay back some
funds he'd misused and of course in
those last years safe from 66 on 67 on
he was dying of cancer and his absentee
record was abysmal always had been but
it was also clear the last few years of
his time he no longer had the energy
when was he the most powerful aha
he was the most powerful in Congress
from January 1961 to September 1966 when
he was chair of the House Education and
Labor Committee he
had during that moment that pot that
period but no other african-american
politician ever had
he had institutional power he was chair
of a major substantive committee the
House Education and Labor Committee keep
in mind we're talking 1960s was the
committee that handled roughly 40% of
the domestic legislation of the United
States and looking with they're talking
about the period of new frontier and the
Great Society when LBJ officially this
president was turning out all all that
legislation Medicare elementary energy
secondary education Oh EO all that
legislation National Defense Education
Act all that legislation came through
his committee and he was the chair of
that committee and for that period I
would say yeah about five year period he
ran a good ship he was it by most
accounts was an effective chairperson
and I'm talking about accounts from not
just his his staff and his friends what
you would expect but from people on his
committee John brattiness for instance
Frank Thompson
you know people on a former congressman
former congressman mm-hmm and his his
chairmanship was really very good he
delegated authority to people Edith
green we didn't like but was also on his
committee he had a superb staff
incidentally particularly committee
staff and this was very important
because he needed it he needed that good
staff to cover him you see and it was a
very effective and substantive person
during that period how often did you
talk with him ah that's a very distinct
start I am
I had three contacts with Adam Clayton
Powell and I spoke to him twice I
the first contact if I can do this very
briefly because it's the most exciting
part of my personal saga with the man
came when I was I like to say this a
young 19 year old recruit in the army it
was in 1949 I was in Camp Hood Texas and
I was down from Chicago and mr. Truman
had just issued orders desegregating the
military well I as a Negro and I like to
use the lexicon of the times it helps
your listeners understand the atmosphere
I could use a dark room the facilities
that photographic facilities except doin
limited periods of time Sunday morning 6
to 11 o'clock I wrote to Adam Clayton
Powell now keep in mind I'm from Chicago
my congressman was a black congressman
William L Dawson I didn't write to him I
didn't write to him because I don't
think I'd get an answer
I wrote to congressman Adam Clayton
Powell from Harlem I didn't hear from
him didn't hear from about three weeks
later my company commander called me in
and said you should be careful about
rabble-rousers your corresponding with
do you know that Adam this congressman
you wrote to call mrs. Truman
president's white the last lady of the
land because that she had refused to
turn down an invitation to the daughters
of American Revolution which had just
excluded at Powell's wife Hazel Scott
from performing in Constitution Hall
so Adam chuckle call last lady of the
land he said now that's my company
president that's not the kind of person
you'd want to correspond this is a
rabble rouser troublemaker disrespectful
I looked on the desk and there was a
letter a memo from the Department of the
army right under that was now standing
at attention remember this
right under that was a letter from Adam
Powell to the Department of the army so
he said now if you have any problems of
company privacy within this man's army
you come to us you know now you can go
ahead and use a darkroom any time you
want to use you know fine that was the
first time never heard from Adam but I
got the he got he and I got the results
the second time was ten years later I
was then a professor I've already
promoted myself I was an assistant
professor at a very major black college
in Alabama
tusky and I was very involved in voter
registration and so forth
so we wanted several senators and
Congress per people to introduce a bill
so we had pile on that list I had an
occasion to talk to him on the phone
then and I was first time ever talked to
Dylan medic third and last time now I am
a professor at Columbia I just gone to
Columbia's now 70 1970 he and I were
invited to appear at a major rally civil
rights rally in Cleveland two main
speakers well he was now running for
reelection against Charlie Rangel it's
very clear also he's dying of cancer and
he's not been spending much time back in
the district he had five opponents
Rangel was just one of them and that was
ideal for him split there and so we were
sitting up late one night as first time
I really met him and we were sitting up
late one night in his hotel room and I
said mr. congressman shouldn't you be
back in the district I hear this is a
close race he looked at me incredulous
Lee said I can't lose they'll vote for
me because they'll remember how
effective I was well I was matter of
fact even so that was the only time I
ever met him second time I'd spoken to
him the third time I've been in contact
with him so I didn't really know him you
know I really did not know him
personally except for those those
instances yeah I remember him well and
my young life here in this town I got a
picture that I picked out
it seemed to me to say a lot and I want
to ask you if it's fair it's this
picture right here the one with the
cigarillo right okay yeah it says I can
remember him standing at microphones and
testifying it having news conferences
and he would use that cigarillo and blow
smoke absolutely the quintessential
arrogant person self-confident
absolutely unfazed in his in his public
persona at that that's Adam Powell yes
where's this picture from the one on the
left this picture is outside Abyssinian
Baptist Church at he's now pretty much
on his last leg the young lady on the
left was his companion at that time and
you could tell he he was not the atom of
old there women played a large role in
his life
absolutely by his own not a cat say
admission by his own account yes how
many times was he married
he's married three times he's married
three times and each one each marriage
had a particular Flair about it
she's just a chlorotic this young yeah
that's his third wife from Puerto Rico
incidentally yes and the young son
interestingly enough Adam Clayton Powell
of fourth was just elected to the City
Council of New York in the footsteps of
his father last month in October sat in
Clayton pile of fourth representing a
district in East Harlem Adam Clayton
Powell the third was the son of Adam of
the congressman and Hazel Scott and I
know he's been here on this network
recently when he was he's in the he's in
the media he's in
journalism yes he's a and apparently has
no interest in the political realm when
you talk about the and we'll get to the
best side when we talk about the worst
side of Adam Clayton Powell what was it
well that's interesting and I and I
appreciate the distinction Adam Powell
would never admit the words having a
worse side oh well look but you and I
can and talk about it you said the worst
side the the clearly the rather careless
disregard for certain things like misuse
of committee funds yeah but that was in
the record there was no doubt of that
some of the his personal activities by
his own admission now the way he
disregarded the court warrants against
him in a libel suit in against him in
Harlem he says I was inattentive I was
neglectful on that that was that was not
good I would also suggest that his
absentee record which a lot of us
excused at the time I would suggest
worked against him and then finally the
part that I found to be as intriguing
some people might not say was from
friend and foe they simply felt they
couldn't trust the man he would enter
into a deal and then you'd find out you
didn't have a deal he was a very complex
fellow in that regard and I think one of
the aspects of this book that I try to
not tiptoe through but try to point up
is that we're not talking here about a
saint and neither I think are we talking
about a a sinner we're talking about a
complex politician who had some very
very
serious negatives about him that people
didn't like cruisers that's hazel Scott
his second wife and that the little baby
is Adam Clayton Powell the third that's
the long we mentioned just earlier did
he know when he was doing all these
things that were bad or what we
characterize you and I would call
negative negative
he would say define that but go ahead
but but did he know that did he do it on
purpose I don't think no haha I think he
understood clearly and the evidence is
throughout the book there what he was
doing and I think he understood that it
was somewhat self destructed but it was
so much a part of him that I don't think
he even if he yes he knew it
yes he knew it but even if his
definition would be somewhat different
from yours of mine he knew that his
having his wife on the payroll when she
wasn't doing any work he knew that that
was not proper
he also excused it by saying he wasn't
the only one he knew that and this is
the record is clear that using airline
tickets inappropriately for staff he
knew that it was whatever else he was he
was not a dumb man first he knew that
another aspect of him though was he was
a fellow who had never as far as I could
tell
been denied anything that he really
wanted and that's not an inconsequential
aspect of understanding a person's
makeup you know I'm not a psychologist
and I purposely don't go into that but
it was so much a part of him the persona
the lifestyle that even if he'd known it
and even if he had defined it the way
you and I are now talking about it I
suspect it wouldn't make that much
difference to him see
but you and I might call and others have
called arrogance he would call
self-confidence
incidentally what some people call a
reckless behavior with women with funds
he would say I'm not a hypocrite and in
all in most of the time he could turn
and I'm not going to sit here in
question whether he he was rationalizing
or not but he could turn what some
people would call negatives into
positives you know and that was very
important about in the sense of trying
to understand who this terribly complex
political figure with plus I must say
this the subtitle of the book the
political biography of an American
dilemma I had great fun with that one
his main issue throughout his career was
civil rights and economic justice and he
always knew that he had those two issues
going for him
and he came home to those issues and he
brought them home always to the pulpit
of Abyssinian Baptist Church and
whenever he was under attack for these
negatives for these faults for these bad
qualities he could say that's why
they're doing it because I am such a
forceful champion of civil rights that's
why they're out to get me what would you
like in the pulpit I want to use words
that are very descriptive and not
hyperbole dynamic unheralded excellence
order excellent preacher
yeah but like a lot of Baptist preachers
you know could take a text and weave it
into either a religious theme or
political thing captured the
parishioners emotionally and in every
other way in a very superb manner now he
was a very very by all accounts I've
never heard anything negative in that
regard
a superb preacher and this was you know
one of the major churches - it's very
impressive
congregation where'd you grow up I grew
up in South Side Chicago where'd you go
screw in Chicago throughout throughout
from the big you know the elementary
through the PhD at University Chicago
Roosevelt University Roosevelt
University major downtown working-class
University late 40s for the BA
I went to Loyola Law School and went to
University of Chicago just you know make
it a little very little normal method
worked at the post office
nothing nothing unusual parents what
they do work in class didn't go to
college my brother and sister and I are
first-generation college and a family
what got you interested in education and
so much education is only way out was
only it was only up with mobility keep
in mind we talking about the 40s 30s 40s
50s it was the it was the normal way you
know like most Americans I didn't have a
big heritage of legacy of money from my
family so you saw the educational roads
not on nothing complicated about that
and so I might have all had done it a
little bit it was fun so you've got an
undergraduate degree in political
science a master's degree political
science a PhD political science and a
law degree
yep took a little time but nothing
little normal kind of an a workaday
world your parents are raising from
Chicago no no no no no no no father
Louisiana I'm mother Texas and they were
part we were part of that they divorced
but we were part of that I was born in
Muskogee Oklahoma
ten days before the crash
October 19th 1929 and who party no part
of the Okies went west
you know Grapes of Wrath the other part
went north we were part of that
depression migration that went north and
so we landed in Chicago in the mid 30s
depth of the depression incidentally I
must say I see your honor but just
itching to Adam Powell and his
background depression right 29:30
on to show you give you you and your
audience a little indication of the
privileged nature of this man
so his biographer is not in the same
category but I think that's developed by
the clear now when he graduated from
Colgate in June of 1930 pretty bad times
his parents sent him on a three-month
cruise to the Mediterranean okay I would
get back to the powered story do you
think that if he were here today and you
could spend an extended amount of time
with him that you'd like him
oh no question because I have developed
very honestly the capacity to a
segregate if I may use that that loaded
language I could see Powell the
politician Powell the public person from
Powell the private or personal character
and I would have the same frustrations
with him in person that I had in writing
the book I would love to spend evenings
with him I would not be a big social
buddy of his no I don't think many
people were incidentally and not for any
reason of choice of mind but I think
that was his age I don't think he
particularly but I would I would be able
to
like him and and be frustrated by him
and I think it's another he would like
that because I think he liked keeping
everybody off this Primus nature by the
way back to your school for schooling
for a while how did you get yourself
through all that you worked all the time
yeah post office well-liked factors and
mostly post office yeah sure work nights
at at the peel your door well T has this
superb short story how I how I came to
live at the PIO
how I came to work at the peel of course
and that going to school and I was the
only one you know I'd love to sit here
and say I'm they of course we all did
that many of us and we leave school as a
well we're you and while I'm going to
the office post on show you
you working at and it was a good way to
do it because you could at that time you
could work four hours a night or eight
hours you know depending on the floor of
the mail and so forth
but it was was a superb employment base
for those of us who were working our way
through god it was decent money
the hours were you know study then we
could go on full-time in the summer you
know which was absolutely
there was tuition to pay five other
books besides just one oh I think so I
you know in my in my yeah I don't
American government yeah the black
tension America yeah black piece of
black experience in American politics
that was an edited book but the yeah
that's a book and bench in the ballot
yep and black power that's what I want
to ask you about black power was Stokely
Carmichael that's yeah that's five go
ahead black power with Stokely
Carmichael you know that when you see
black power
the C's Stokely Carmichael that I got to
ask you about Stokely Carmichael yeah
today known as Kwame Toure he would he
would have you and me no but he do you
still talk to Stoker absolutely when he
comes to town we he what he'll call he's
you know he's on the lecture circuit and
he splits his time I think between here
and and Africa oh sure he calls me and
we try to get together you know it
becomes increasingly difficult but sure
what was the book what was the book what
was the message
aha I can sit here and tell you that I'm
going to but I the question but there
were so many messages in that concept
what year we're talking now 66 67 cities
are blowing up burn baby burn
get hongki's and so forth the message in
black and Stokely Carmichael being one
of the if not D at that moment major
spokespersons for that concept so the
term had many connotations the book
however was surprising to a lot of
people because it was not as
inflammatory as some people thought but
I keep telling people with that the book
had one central meaning for me and it
had to do with group cohesion it had to
do with block voting politics something
I was never ashamed of and there was a
phrase in the book that I wish I had put
it in the front page and every other
page throughout the book before a group
can enter the open society it must first
close ranks and that's what Black Power
was to me and it still is and that's why
I'm more I think an advocate of black
power today than I was then perhaps
because I'm more knowledgeable about it
in other words I see something quite
affirmative and positive about group
cohesion and not negative I see the fact
that community
these can coalesce I mean come together
the same way the Irish did in Boston I
remember John Kennedy saying one time
you understand his presidency to the
extent that you understand he came out
of an Irish Catholic base in Boston I
find that to be quite acceptable and
growing up in South Side Chicago I know
about Irish politics and Cook County
Democratic Party but we I was attempting
to do in black power was to say blacks
have to get themselves together then
they can enter into coalitions with
other groups what was always on my mind
then and now is the ultimate attainment
of a free and open society and my
problem with that book and subsequently
is that I didn't spend enough time
explicating that but I'm not too sure we
could have at any rate the cities were
blowing up the Black Panthers were only
on this scene people were events events
events events were taking over people
were defining black powers kick whites
out of the civil rights movement
separatism that was a big word that used
to drive me up the wall oh you a Black
Power advocate you are a separatist yeah
the same way John Kennedy is an
irish-catholic was a separatist you know
where were you in those years
ah well let's see I was at Lincoln
University black college in Pennsylvania
and then I was at Roosevelt in Chicago
in Chicago and then I came to Columbia
so we're talking 66 through 70 let us
say I was at those places there's nobody
I would think alive during those periods
it could would be able to forget Stokely
Carmichael stump speech yeah and he
became more of a revolutionary after the
book it's a day doing and after the book
you know Pan Africanist we don't know so
question in fact in August of 67 a month
before the book came out
he was in Havana Cuba with Castro making
very very strong revolutionary
statements and so the the evolution of
Carmichael didn't quite square in the
minds of many people with the language
of the book and so they really brought
to the book the lang the subsequent
language and imagery of Stokely
Carmichael as they were seeing it on the
television how did you two get together
well known each other in the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating Committee was
always involved in some way or other
even when I left the South in voter
registration in the South and I would go
back periodically do engage in voter
registration workshops for snick the
Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee got to know Stokely and some
of the others that way
I was always though the the professor
you know they were younger but I was a
little older and there were several of
us who played that kind of quasi
advisory role professor Sinclair Drake
was one of them and you know you get to
know you got to know them several of
them that way and that's how Carmichael
and I got together Stokely Carmichael
left this country went to Africa yeah
came a citizen over there I don't know I
don't know DNA you might have but I
don't know how would you two sitting
side-by-side on this stage right here
differ today I suspect he would be more
overtly a pan-african ness I think he
would be much more overtly interested in
that kind of struggle he would be less
interested I think than I in the
intricacies of electoral politics in the
United States I'm still interested in
getting people elected to sheriffs and
County Assessors and mayors and so forth
and I'm interested in
liberal progressive democratic politics
small D I think that he would see that
as on the periphery of the major I
suspect on the he would be more
interested in the more global aspects of
the social struggle I would think so
picture in your book on Adam Clayton
Powell jr. this is congressman Powell
there and in the middle Malcolm X and
Dick Gregory yeah can you put it all in
context Malcolm X why is there so much
interest in Malcolm X today oh that's
very interesting n killed assassinated
in February 65 on the scene much shorter
time than say Powell I think there was
something very dynamic about both his
life and death I think that he was
articulating a message that particularly
the earlier part of his life before the
break with the Nation of Islam that was
quite appealing to an awful lot of
people I think and indeed I believe that
I hope I'm not misunderstood here but I
think that there's something very
intriguing and I hope I'm not
misunderstood the same with King about
the dynamic modder
type way they were fill'd assassination
snap you know stuffed out like that I
think there are you know all those
reasons he apparently was undergoing
transformation after his break with the
Nation of Islam where was he going
I know we talked about a year and not
you right there all this iterative I
just supervised day very interesting PhD
dissertation on him at Columbia very
interesting a lot of lot of
attention to that but he let his Malcolm
X's career lends itself to that sort of
analysis it's it's a very different
career to than this man you look long
and hard and Mister and Malcolm X never
registered anybody to vote never got a
piece of legislation through Congress
and yet I would never denigrate his
career but it's a very different impact
and incidentally that's what made how
angry and jealous of those people why
all this attention to Malcolm he never
got he didn't even lead a march you know
it's a very interesting aspect of the of
the story of the black struggle it's
what the cameras are turned to and
Powell at that point he was a little bit
now we're talking early 60s he was even
with his power in Congress he was still
a little apprehensive that perhaps this
young man Malcolm X fiery speaker do you
ever hear of course oh yes in his own
backyard remember Harlem not Pittsburgh
not Louisville Harlem that he might rise
up to challenge pow
so all that dynamism and this man who
spanned all these years who saw the
evolution of this the Kings the Malcolm
X's had a little bit of a time adjusting
to it you know because he could see in
them his earlier self because he was the
fiery stomp platform speaker in the 30s
and 40s and indeed into the 50s
now new leaders come along King Malcolm
many others and the TV cameras aren't on
it now where is he
well he's in Congress doing very
important things running committees
running a committee getting legislation
passed liberal progressive that's not
what the cameras are where the camera is
well I'll tell you where they are
they're at Lincoln Memorial in August of
63 well where was Powell well he was
assigned to leading a little delegation
congressional delegation to sit off on a
platform they were the cameras when
Birmingham where was Powell when the
dogs were jumping and biting people
Powell was holding a subcommittee
meeting or something Selma Alabama
so-called silver and so forth when use
and he was angry because of that jealous
jealous and it was the dynamism of the
movement and so a lot of people said ah
the movements passing power by he didn't
like that if you put Adam Clayton Powell
and Stokely Carmichael and Malcolm X and
you in a room alone without these
cameras without me sitting there asking
you questions and you were going over
the last 30 years
you can add anybody to that group you
wanted the point of the question is
assuming that you all had the same goal
improving life for the black citizen
what worked and what didn't work did the
fiery speech work did it get the right
kind of attention
did the marches I mean analyzed it from
you know if you if you start out with a
campaign in the 60s moving forward and
now looking back just in question
and let me be very brief by saying I'll
tell you the one thing that I think
didn't work and then because I'm very
eclectic I think most of those things
worked and most of them were necessary
and most of them were probably
unpredictable the one thing that didn't
work and we should have spent much more
time guarding against it was the
injection of the gun the moment our
struggle became associated with the gun
and I don't mean violence because most
of that struggle is not violent
you know most of that struggle was not
violence the violence was heaped on us
not us on the moment became associate
and I don't mean the rioting either that
was a nom ik that was a function of a
reaction to an atomic act Watts the
police arrest and so forth no that ran
its course - I didn't consider that part
of the civil rights struggle but the
moment I'll struggle the civil rights
movement became associated with the gun
and we started seeing people walk out of
college buildings with rifles and so fun
servants over you know that or walk into
a state legislative halls with rifles
Lou intro rat Brown yes yeah that and he
had other roles but that one was not not
a useful one yeah the moment it became
associated with that it was on a
downward course a bit downward course in
the sense of a no-win course everything
else we did the marches the fiery
speeches the you know the the challenge
of the the uncompromising challenge in
64 of the at the Democratic Party
Mississippi Democratic / all that all
that the sit-ins
okay all that civil disobedience all
that it's positive we lost control
of that and I think was all hit in that
direction but your camera show am i
pointing the trajectory up but the
moment it became associated with the gun
and all the talk and now that fiery
speeches on the talk about revolution
and don't dress it up I mean physical
revolution that's when we turned a
corner or whatever metaphor you want to
use started down here
that was the detrimental part that
didn't work everything else I'm not
going to apologize for excluding Martin
Luther King and you look back over those
years who were the leaders you thought
had the most positive impact some of the
people we've talked about here with
others oh sure
well some of them are very prominent at
the time I if I can just be at homonym
fannie lou hamer just a fantastic
inspiration both in Mississippians and
then when she testify and out of
Mississippi very important civil rights
worker with snick and so forth when she
was saying O Lord you would listen and
you would tap your foot people like that
Ella Baker who was just absolutely
supportive of snick and King I there's a
giant and they're not all in that and
and I'm going to name people who would
who would at the moment at
cross-purposes with each other for
various reasons there was a giant just
had a booklet in the bottom that I think
it was a superb book didn't get enough
but Clarence Mitchell Clarence Mitchell
was a one of the most effective people
in the city of Washington for two
decades that I can know one of the most
effective lobbyists hasn't a giant oh
you know and and there are a lot of
others and that's the that's the aspect
of the dynamism of this struggle both in
the legal realm you know obviously
they're good Marshall and all those
kinds of people
Jim farmer of Cour
a lot of times we look back on it now
and a lot of the teaching going on I
think I think as I look at some of the
materials tends to state our struggle in
this contentious dichotomous way Malcolm
versus Martin and so forth or are they
coming together or where they hit it
apart and so forth NAACP versus Student
Nonviolent and I was a part of a lot of
that I understand that the Young Turks
against the old guard what that really
was
was a struggle working itself out what
what do you think of this process so far
with your book it's been out a little
bit you've been doing some shows and
interviews I mean do you like when you
envisioned the rollout on this is it
going the way you wanted it to what what
an interesting question I didn't realize
a host would ask that kind of question
isn't it been that interesting uh I
assume I'm not a pro at this I'm a
professor you know I'm really and I'm
really it's a very reasons an
interesting question is it's probably
the only time I'll be asked that you and
my publisher assume yes to that question
but okay I I think that it's it's a
useful process that's not a you know
it's not an overnight read I always say
to people it's not an overnight write
and research so why do you think it has
to be an overnight read and you know if
it takes time to get through it I'm
trying to make a number of subtle and
not so subtle points and but I really
believe in the subject I believe in in
the in the in the product so I like this
up to a point when I think that I'm not
being sufficiently articulate to make
the points I wanted to make then I get
angry with myself but if I took time to
research and write the book and try to
get it right okay then I ought to take
time to try to explain to those who are
thinking about whether they want to buy
it or not whether it's worth their time
to read this book how to take time to
explain that so I I think the process is
an important one
some of us obviously a better at it than
others I sometimes wish that I would be
able to read and research and write the
book then I'll clone somebody who could
then go on the circuit it would be much
better at responding to very interesting
questions like that you see
when did you start Adam Clayton Powell
died in April 4th 1972 same day four
years earlier that King was killed
April 4th night he died April 4th 1972
our first interview was December 1972
with one of his old colleagues Jay
Raymond Jones I interviewed him in st.
Thomas then I put it aside
I kept gathering data on Harlem and
politics and so forth but I didn't pick
it up again until the mid 80s I would
say you know there's never as you would
understand you are a specific cutoff
date or a start but I would say I spent
the last four and a half to five years
on the book continuously week after week
intensively gathering data going to the
archives the library's Library of
Congress of presidential libraries so I
would say four and a half to five years
weekly every week that is on that book
your most valuable source of information
archival materials particularly the
presidential libraries of Johnson in
Austin Texas and Eisenhower and Abilene
Kansas Library of Congress had superb
work on Miss on NACP papers oh I got six
thousand six hundred pages of FBI
materials through the Freedom of
Information Act
very good out of oral history materials
from Columbia University library some
materials from shop so it's archival
material Schaumburg library in New York
then followed by interviews selected
interviews with people who one were
available to talk to him talk to me
about him and then two and there were
some very good interviews and I
particularly wanted people who were on a
staff you know and I got a superb set of
interviews there on his colleagues some
of his colleagues there I must tell you
first of all that was a part of it that
was part of the put off incidentally for
taking so long
would you know it mr. Powell
as was his wand didn't leave any
systematic collection of papers you know
and so that that worried me a bit you
know well how do I get my head and I was
in I was in sistent on doing a heavily
documented study I did not want to do an
impression istic one or one based
substantially or exclusively on
interviews I wanted heavily document
when I'm a professor and that was very
important to me so IVA said well gee can
I get good solid primary data it's all
the answer is yes his letters that he
wrote you know that rope people wrote
there were in these other places
something unusual that pops out of your
book is that he supported Dwight
Eisenhower instead of at my students
yeah and there are a lot of reasons for
that his own and others I don't think
there was anything
mr. Paul did for which there were not at
least multiple reasons a lot of people
said ah look at that he's under
investigation for his income taxes now
we're talking fifty-five fifty-six and
so if he cuts a deal with the
Republicans they said the Republicans
will ease up on investigating his income
taxes that's one reason another reason
was his own you want to know why I
supported Eisen her because he's better
than Stephenson on civil rights well not
many civil rights people believe that so
that there were a lot of reasons why he
supported Eisenhower and they're always
mixed up with the political professional
and personal explanations but he
survived it he almost got in trouble
with in terms of denying in his seats
his seniority in Congress but he
survived that's something else that was
intriguing about this man as you go
along you would say oh there goes a time
jumping off a roof again and you're
right but even land on his feet you will
be most happy when all the dust clears
on this book if what happens well very
interestingly enough excluding the
commercial aspect of that that question
I would like to see interestingly enough
of course re-examination of him and his
life but you know that'll that'll happen
at any rate there'll be more thing but I
want to see this serve as a sort of
further spur to the examination of other
stories not just biographies but other
complex stories about the movement we've
been very simplistic I think in
explaining this very important American
struggle we've been very simplistic good
guys against the bad guys right or wrong
and this this life is strictly simply a
account of the complexity of that
struggle and so if people can read this
book and say yeah well let's look at
some
the people and some other episodes in
that kind of way I would be very happy
that would be very happy this is what
the book looks like Adam Clayton Powell
jr. political biography an American
dilemma by Charles B Hamilton Thank You
professor thank you sir for having me